on display at piccadilly circus ai
weiwei is asking where do we go from
here
part of the circa art movement this
challenge comes just ahead of cop 26 as
known for his political activism as his
art now he's speaking out on climate
change we always point the finger to
others
deforestation
and
pollution
all done by a human
he fears the climate conference might
not make much difference
probably it's too late
and the most likely
nothing will change we cannot depend on
one
meeting
famously designing the bird's nest
stadium for the 2008 beijing olympics
life became increasingly difficult for
ai weiwei after he spoke out against the
chinese government he eventually left
china in 2015 but the artist defends how
his home country's greenhouse emissions
have come to exceed all developed
nations pointing out that china's 1.4
billion people per capita produce less
greenhouse emissions than the us
what china did every nation did before
so
to use one standard to to measure
everything which is very colonial and
very discriminative whatever agreements
are reached at cop26 ai weiwei believes
china is capable of change
once they made a clear policy
they can
follow their
their decisions
and
if they really want they can do
do
anything to
to achieve their plan the artist who has
always spoken out against the status quo
says we all need to take a stand
if you don't act
or if you're not conscious about what is
going
wrong
i think
it's a tragic to your own life
i think
this is a
responsibility of being human to take
care of human conditions
for ai weiwei not only is it clear that
we need to act on climate he believes
it's also time to look at how we in the
west are quick to point the finger
katie spencer sky news